♪♪
-Hello, everyone, and welcome
to Thanksgiving "Corrections."
We're putting this out
a day early,
because it's Thanksgiving,
and...
if we're not thankful
for "Corrections,"
what is there
to be thankful for?
I mentioned Flamin' Hot Cheetos,
and I talked about the sauce.
I was corrected.
Flamin' Hot Cheetos
do not have a sauce on them.
They have a dust on them.
Which I should have remembered
from the famous Cheetos slogan,
"Mmm.
That's good dust."
[ Laughter ]
I mispronounced the member
of a crew team
that does the steering.
I pronounced it "cock-swain,"
which is incorrect.
It's "cock-sun."
In my defense, I pronounced it
the way it's spelled.
But, of course, that's not
good enough at old Oxford.
Oh, "cock-swain" -- how quaint.
[ Laughter ]
That's how they get you.
At Oxford.
'Cause then you say to them,
"Well, how do you pronounce it?"
and they say,
"Oh, perhaps you'll buy
one of our dictionaries."
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to go to Oxford,
I don't want to go to Cambridge.
You imagine
going to Cambridge?
Spending every day
worried you were
about to get recruited
to be a Russian spy.
[ Laughter ]
"We love the Cambridge Four,
don't we?"
[ Laughter ]
We love 'em.
Burgess, Blunt, Philby,
and Maclean.
"Cambridge Four!
They added a fifth later.
Cairncross --
didn't care for him."
It is helpful that it is
pronounced "cock-sun"
and not the way it's spelled,
because that's how they caught
a lot of the kids
in that admissions scandal.
They would bring them in
at, say, Yale or Dartmouth,
and they'd say,
"Oh, I see here you did crew."
They'd say, "Yeah, I did crew."
And they'd say,
"Now, I'm just wondering,
did you have someone helping you
with the steering wheel,
with your backs to the action
while you're rowing?"
"Yeah. Yeah, we did."
And they'd say,
"Just out of curiosity,
what did you call that person?"
"Uh, well, you know,
we'd call them Fred."
[ Laughter ]
"F-Fred did m-most
of the steering."
"So, yeah, but did Fred
have a job?
Like, what would you call --
what would call Fred's role
in the crew team?"
They'd go, "Uh...
..."cock-swain"?
-"Get out!"
[ Laughter ]
We showed a graphic
of Joe Flacco --
Jets quarterback Joe Flacco --
wearing the number 5.
He's the number 19.
In our defense, Joe Flacco
was on the Jets last year.
He left the Jets
as a free agent.
He was then traded
back to the Jets.
He was 5 last year.
He's 19 this year.
So, slightly defensible,
but we heard
from a lot of Jets fans,
because if there is one thing
Jets fans demand,
it is error-free execution.
[ Laughter ]
We did --
The reason we had a joke
about Joe Flacco
is he admitted --
to his credit, he admitted
he was not vaccinated
against COVID Five --
COVID-19 -- did it again.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm wondering, do you think
he would have got vaccinated
if the vaccine protected you
from being traded
back to the Jets?
[ Laughter ]
If it like 95% prevented you
from being traded back
to the Jets.
I feel like, at that point,
you'd stop doing
your own research.
"I got COVID twice."
"You think you got it bad?"
[ Laughter ]
This is embarrassing.
We implied...
that you send Beetlejuice away
by saying his name three times,
but. of course, you summon
Beetlejuice by saying his name
three times.
I don't -- I do not know
if this will work, but, um...
Beetlejuice, Beetlejuice,
Beetlejuice.
[ FaceTime ringing ]
Nope.
As a consolation prize,
this is my impression of me
asking Michael Keaton...
[ Ringtone plays ]
[ Laughter ]
Someone's calling me.
[ Ringtone continues ]
[ FaceTime call ends ]
Oh.
[ FaceTime ringing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ FaceTime call starts ]
-Hey. What's up?
Yeah, do, uh --
do Beetlejuice.
-"Uh, you hate sandworms?
Can't stand 'em myself."
[ Croaks ]
-[ Laughs ]
Love you.
[ Laughter ]
Worth every one
of the three phone calls.
[ Laughter ]
Um -- Oh, so we've made
a few jokes about --
It was in the news.
It was reported
in a lot of the news that,
in a new comic, Superman...
would come out --
was gonna come out as bisexual.
Now, I should clarify,
and a lot of people
are very happy
with the number of
comic-book fans
who watch this show.
It's not Clark Kent Superman
who came out as bisexual.
It's his son, Jonathan Kent,
who sometimes serves
the role of Superman.
And they've been
the most lovely comments,
because it is comic-book fans
who care very much
about getting the details right,
who also want to make it clear
they're not upset about
the sexuality part of it.
So, like, "It's not Superman!
That would be fine."
[ Laughter ]
But it's Jonathan Kent
who is bisexual, and, you know,
Clark Kent,
the Superman we know, um...
I think his sexuality
is very clear.
He doesn't he doesn't go back
and forth, right?
He stays in his lane.
[ Laughter ]
I like that joke so much
that I, um...
I reached out and asked
if I can get a Superman T-shirt
because I was going to think
about ripping this open
and having it.
And I mentioned to Eric --
incredibly talented man who
runs our wardrobe department --
and he said,
"You want to do what?"
[ Laughter ]
Mentioned baby carrots.
I got some very interesting
feedback on baby carrots.
Two kinds of baby carrots.
There are baby carrots you grow.
But there are also
baby-cut carrots.
These are carrots, I think,
that are more common
in a supermarket.
These are cut
from regular-sized carrots
and have far less
nutritional value
than baby-grown carrots
versus baby-cut carrots and...
someone -- a jackal posited
that they think that
the baby-cut carrots
come from carrots
that are so misshapen
that people wouldn't buy them.
So that's how they're making --
they're still getting
their carrot money out of it.
But you have to be careful
if you ever --
and I'm not recommending
you do this.
If you ever buy
your baby carrots
on the black market,
just know that
your connect, if you will,
might do a thing,
which is very common
in this kind of deal,
where they'll show up
with a duffel bag
or, you know,
some of the fancier guys
still use briefcases,
and what they'll do is, they'll
show you the baby carrots,
and they'll put the good
baby carrots up top.
But then underneath,
it's just baby-cut carrots.
So you just have to --
just know, reach --
before you pay the money
for your baby carrots,
you know, dig in the bottom.
You know, it's --
I use a jeweler's loop.
[ Laughter ]
You look for a cut.
And then if you still
can't tell --
This is weird, and
I know this sounds like a bit.
The way you can tell is,
you go like this.
[ Laughter ]
And then if you feel like
you've been ripped off,
it's very important to just look
and, you know,
look at your dealer
and say something
along the lines of like,
"Do you take me for a fool?"
[ Laughter ]
Corn.
I said corn was a vegetable.
A lot of feedback on that.
Not -- I still don't have
any clarity.
USDA says
it's a starchy vegetable.
Some of you said it's a grain.
Some of you said it's a grain
when you take it off the cob.
It's a vegetable
when you have it on the cob.
But it did, you know --
led me to my research, which --
You know, sometimes
the best part about Corrections
is that I'm learning new things
to impart upon you.
This is a true story about corn.
The first Thanksgiving,
the Pilgrims, 1621,
they invited
the Wampanoag tribe,
and they said to the leader,
"We would like to have you
for Thanksgiving."
And the head of the Wampanoag
tribe said, "Great.
Is there anything we can bring?"
And they said,
"Sure. A vegetable."
So then it's Thanksgiving Day,
and the Wampanoag tribe
shows up with corn.
And one of the Pilgrims,
a woman --
I don't want
to be critical of her.
The Pilgrims famously had
a very hard first year --
rough winter, new land,
left all their friends behind,
long boat ride.
So there are reasons
that they would maybe be rude.
But what happened is the
Wampanoag showed up and said,
"Here's our vegetable,"
and they brought their corn,
and this female Pilgrim, like,
mumbled and her breath
and said,
"If ya call corn a vegetable."
[ Laughter ]
And that was, um --
That was the first Jacksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
I said some things wrong.
Couple of flubs.
I said Ray-Mans glasses
instead of Ray-Bans.
I said "skate bark"
instead of "skate park."
And I said "Traders Joe's."
Which I think sounds better.
We say -- Someone said,
"You say this a lot
and you're getting it wrong."
Semblance of normalcy.
And I will -- that does sound
like something Sal would write.
Technically,
the correct vocabulary
is "semblance of normality,"
and this is fascinating.
Warren Harding,
President Warren Harding
in the '20s gave a speech
where he had a malaprop,
and he accidentally said
"semblance of normalcy,"
and then that became acceptable,
even though it's not --
was not a word
before he said it wrong,
and that just goes to show you
you can make a mistake
that then becomes accepted.
A hundred years from now,
we might all call it
Traders Joe's.
[ Laughter ]
I am now very excited to...
give what I think is the best
Correction I will ever give.
I feel very confident
this is the best Correction
I will ever give.
I have said on this show
many times
that I am the father of two.
That is incorrect.
For the last 10 weeks,
I have been the father of three.
10 weeks ago, my wife gave
birth to a beautiful baby girl.
Usually, this is something
I would announce on the show,
but we all decided
that Corrections
could use the traffic.
[ Laughter ]
Her name is --
And I should say you --
We knew what we were going
to name her for a long time.
And you have to be careful.
I think everyone who's ever
had a kid knows this.
You want to be careful
telling people the name
before a baby is born
because some people
in your family
might go so far as to tell you
why they don't like it,
and that ruins it for you,
so you have to wait.
You wait until the baby's born,
and then you say what the name
is because it's too late
at that point
for anybody to say anything.
However, some of us --
some of us have people
in our families
who will still comment on a name
after it's too late
to change it.
I have a sister-in-law.
Love her very much.
Dear, dear friend of mine.
Knew her before I knew my wife.
Her name escapes me.
[ Laughter ]
But my sister-in-law --
And let me say
if you don't have -- if you
don't have a sister-in-law,
get -- go out
and get one posthaste.
They are -- It's the --
It's like your wife
with none of the intimacy
and all of the opinions.
[ Laughter ]
So, we had our first son.
We named him Ashe,
which is my wife's maiden name.
And his middle name is Olson,
which is my mother's
maiden name.
And we thought
it was a beautiful tribute
to two incredible women.
And my sister-in-law,
when she heard that we named
our son Ashe Olson Meyers, said,
"Are you worried people
will think you named him
after Ashley Olsen?"
And I immediately said,
"I don't think a single person
will think that."
They might think
it sounds like Ashley Ols--
I don't think a single person
will be like,
"Well, you know Seth.
If there's anyone he was
going to pay tribute to..."
I mean, I've never even --
I've never even seen
an episode of "Full House."
Name a kid...
Lovely person.
I've met her. Lovely.
But name a kid after
Ashley Olsen? I mean...
[ Laughter ]
So...that's the risk.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
I completely --
Sometimes I lo-- All right.
So, the baby's name.
We named her Mary Kate.
[ Laughter ]
If you want to hear her name,
if you want to see pictures,
if you want to hear the story,
you have to watch
the Thanksgiving episode,
which is on tonight.
My parents are on,
and this is something
that we're just
gonna start doing more.
We're gonna use this show
to promote Corrections,
Corrections to promote the show.
Shoemaker, you've always said
your favorite word -- "synergy."
[ Laughter ]
This was a joke
I decided not to do
because it tonally
didn't seem right
based on the emotion
of having a new kid.
I was gonna say,
"Do you guys want to see
a picture of my baby?"
Again, I'm not gonna do this
'cause, tonally, it's wrong.
Say, "You guys want to see
a picture of my new baby?"
And then I'd show this,
and then I'd go, "Which
one of you was with her?!"
[ Laughter ]
It's Thanksgiving, and...
I am thankful for a lot.
Many things are new
about my life
that weren't true last year.
Beautiful baby girl
is one of them.
Another one -- less important
but also lovely --
is the advent of Corrections.
And I just want to say
doing this every week
makes my life
a little bit better.
And I couldn't do it
without you.
So as much as I hate
to say this,
I want to share that...
I am thankful for every one
of you that takes the time
to leave a comment
on our YouTube page.
We are off for a week.
See me in two.